[Musique]
ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Oh
d'or Aviv
[Musique]
plus
la cuisine
[Musique]
Non
Oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oh
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole prononcée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la milonga bolchevique Attalla définitivement
impossible
aha vision c'est plus fort
[Musique]
dépôts alors que l'obscurité est une nuit argentée
un peu de mentalité
qui devrait recevoir pitié madame l'
équipe de Sophiatown
[Musique]
il a pensé à l'intérieur social qui
sera facilement
[Musique]
dépend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous servons comme une équipe vous savez
- OH
mon  chien le docteur
Milius
[Musique]
Assad régime d'allah azzawajal est une
parabole
[Musique]
Oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc
[Mus  ic]
[Musique]
comme vous
GC l'appelez la
[Musique]
la :
mec
[Musique]
est-ce que
vous avez l'
air mec larme et retournez
[Musique]
Oh
l'ambiance
[Musique]
extraterrestres
Andy
[Musique  ]
nous
[Musique]
et ils sortent
écoute peut-être qu'ils m'ont dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements  ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
voir
immédiatement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
[Musique]